mark munoz 23 on twitter said what would
you say to someone wanting to run for
congress but has no idea
where to start well mark
uh what what a great question and i i
say
uh i actually read a chapter about this
in my book that's upcoming
there are books out there that talk
about like the right way to run for
congress
um you know um but
uh in my opinion there may not be any
right way to run for congress there are
a number of people
who supported the presidential campaign
who decided to take the plunge
here on yank speaks we recently talked
to two of them wendy hamilton erica
rhodes
and they had some background of activism
um i think it's a real act of courage uh
and vision for both of them
um so mark there are resources that will
tell you the right way uh you know
what one thing to do is to get involved
with local politics
another thing is just to try and take it
on um
and see what you can do uh blair
walshingham is another person that comes
to mind for me she eventually raised
over a hundred thousand dollars and
became the democratic nominee
um in her district in in tennessee the
first thing i'd ask you is why you want
to do it
um you have a really powerful reason to
run and
if that powerful reason is something
where andrew has like i think we need to
rewrite the rules the economy then you
should shoot for the moon if there's
like an awareness thing or that sort of
thing but if it's
mainly which is a lot of people running
is like i think i would be better at
this than most people because i'm a good
person i'm well read i'm
articulate passionate like people then
you gotta find the right race to run in
um and sometimes it's starting local and
like building up slowly um and you can
stay at those
offices for like short periods of time
you're not time out waiting your time on
a bench for years and years and years
um but the reality is you have to raise
a bunch of money so you got to look and
see who can
who can actually who in my network who
are my friends or friends who in the
democratic party would actually be open
to
giving me ten twenty hundred thousand
whatever yeah
or or another party um and so yeah or
republican
yeah the the rule of thumb uh for a
congressional campaign
um is to imagine that you have to raise
three hundred thousand dollars
in order to run in like a normal
district
um which is frankly well beyond the
reach of like the vast majority of
humans
uh in in this country i mean you know
like like who's gonna and
it it's not like you can have a rich
uncle just give you 300k either i mean
there's going to be a contribution
like a ton of people yeah so uh so mark
that
that that is the rule of thumb or the
conventional wisdom i i will say that
sometimes [ __ ] the conventional wisdom i
mean who cares but that that is
something
that um you know the the quote-unquote
experts
uh said as a benchmark the problem with
politics
it gets easier the longer you do it they
get you know so if you've been if you're
if you're a state rep
then it's easier to run for congress and
if you're congress it's easy to run for
senator like people
the establishment it's an institution
right it's like finance it's like
insurance it's a there's a whole
machinery around it
now that said i'm with andrew sometimes
just gotta blow the whole thing up which
we did i think i would say this if you
feel it in your heart you should do it
um and it's hard but it's super
rewarding most people talk about it done
it like it's frustrating if you don't
win
um but i know a lot of people who ran
and did not win
and uh they almost always grew a ton as
a result
and and i think that's true for people
who run for lots of different offices so
i'd encourage you to run mark um and if
not for congress maybe for something
else like i genuinely think it'll
make you a bigger person certainly i
grew a ton
you know running for office and i would
be here
hanging talking to zach and all of you
right now that's for sure
um and uh the last question i see here
is from
sunnyvale andrew if you could talk to
your younger self what would you say
zack let me hit you with that what would
you tell a young zack
i would tell me to take more risk like i
wish i had jumped on an andrew yang
bandwagon
or plan earlier um because i think
i think we're all in these you're in
this like we're all in these
whether it's lanes for some people where
it's like you go middle school and high
school and college
for some or it's like you feel like
you're trapped in this and i think
um if you can take a crazy risk or get
off that beaten path
um you should um because we need
people that's where all that's where all
the fun stuff happened because everybody
and their mother said
andrew you should not run for president
you have no reason doing it everybody
there's not one per there's like oh you
know a small handful of people that said
go ahead and do it but the vast majority
were like you're effing nuts
and it was the right decision 10
10 fold right um so i wish to me i wish
i'd like learn to think outside the box
a little differently and
try and get off that path sooner so
that's what i would say um
but in one ways i would want to change
it because i ended up where i am i'm
working with you so
oh well thank you zach that means a ton
to me man i i'm
i'm so like thrilled and proud uh
that you and i work together like it's
it's really an honor to
to be able to work with you brother what
would you say to your young self
for me i know it would be the advice
that i probably could not never follow
um which was just to try and take it
easier on myself when i was younger when
i was younger i was always so
brought up and caught up and just like
down on myself because like i you know
didn't do enough wasn't uh good enough
and whatever it was
um and or like uh
you know women didn't like me or call me
back and it would like you know make me
sad for
days and days and days just like if i
could tell myself just like man just
you know be at ease like things end up
working out for you in ways that you
can't imagine
like it's good to try and genuinely like
enjoy yourself in these moments but
i was very bad at that when i was
younger i really
wasn't terribly at ease or laid back
about what my present or future held and
i always felt like i needed to be
doing something more uh yeah that there
wasn't
as much joy as there could have been
when i was young um
i had this strange exercise act that
happens to me now where
i i'm trying to go to sleep and maybe i
can't sleep
at night or at least easily i sleep
quite well just everyone knows but
um but like maybe you know there's like
there are a few minutes when when like
you're having hurt him getting to sleep
and i start counting um just one two
three four five and then each number
i try and remember something from that
year of my life
so obviously i can't remember anything
like one two three and then four start
remembering something five
and i'm not remembering anything
specific it's like an image or a flash
or an emotion
uh and then i just keep going five six
seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve
uh and uh you know and then eventually
i'm getting into you know like 25
30 30 i don't like remembering like you
know who i was and
at least maybe like a moment of
something i experienced uh during that
year of my life
uh and then by the time i get to 46
which is where i am now
um you know i'm sort of like in the
present and somehow it relaxes me
somehow like imagining this arc
of like you know like like the the years
of my life like you know that then i
kind of feel more at rest
but if you look at like the way i was in
year
24 25 26 27 i was like always so
tense and uh um
trying to figure it out uh you know
trying to make progress
a lot of the times when i couldn't make
progress i would just do something that
gave me a feeling of progress
that you can control so like the basic
one during those years for me was going
to the gym it's like well like you know
maybe
uh you know maybe relationships aren't
exactly materializing the way i want or
maybe my career is not going the way i
want but
i can pump this iron max today yeah
yeah like i could do that um
and uh you know and you can argue
whether that was like a healthier uh
unhealthy way to channel that feeling uh
but i had that feeling
my entire uh um
20s i'd say um i met evelyn when i was
31
and i thank goodness that i didn't meet
her until then because i
just started to mellow out enough so
that
when you know she met me that i could i
i could
like be someone that frankly you could
build like a healthy long-term
relationship with
and if she had met me at any other point
i she like would not have
we would not be married today like i i i
know this 100
in part zach um because i don't know if
people know this but so i
just like start you know going out with
evelyn um
and then uh after like a few dates um
she writes me an email
and says like hey i don't think we
should see each other anymore um
and uh and then i take this email
and like i'm saddened obviously um but
then i genuinely
write her back about how like yeah you
know i totally understand you should
like
um go uh like enjoy yourself and like
you know have great experiences because
she'd come out of like a
long-term relationship at that point and
so she wrote me being like essentially
the like i'm not
ready to actually date anyone um
and so i said like yeah like totally get
it like you know like uh
like i want you to um um to go do
like uh whatever it is that you know you
wish you'd been doing this past period
of months and i hit send on this email
and then i genuinely like sat down on my
couch was like okay i'm never going to
see her again and that was very sad but
like i was actually able to accept it
and i would never have been able to
accept it in any kind of like
even moderately healthy way when i was
29 28 27 like i would have been like
completely
keyed up and then if i had written her
back in like it would have come through
like how wounded i was um
um but because i was like at least
somewhat at peace with it
um at the age of 31 she then called me
like a couple days later and was like
hey what are you doing you want to like
obviously it was like mystified me
completely because i was like i thought
i was not too yeah we just broke out
yeah you see you again
uh but i am free and so i just you know
went to where they were
and then the next night i would like say
like the same thing happened several
nights in a row where i was like hey
what are you doing
hey what are you doing and then each
time even after i'd go out and hang out
with her and her friends somewhere
i'd be like and never going to see her
again and like it just happened several
times
right so um
you know so i i would try and go back in
time and tell myself to relax
but i you know i just wasn't capable of
it at that point so if you're young and
you can relate to that
um just so you know you you do mellow
out at least i did
i i think you're like a relatively
intense guy in like a i'm
in a productive way so i'm curious to
think you're
curious to imagine what intense andrew
is
like younger andrew um how much of a
workhorse you probably were
that's what you're talking about but um
your answer made me
rethink mine is like honest like as a
kid you
i wish i knew uh not to care what other
people think so much
you know there's a dr seuss other quotes
like uh
be you are say we feel i think because
those who mind don't matter and those
who matter don't mind
and it's like if you can't be yourself
you don't want to be around those people
if people don't like you for who you are
you don't want to be around them anyway
um
i wish i knew that at a younger age i
kind of learned that in college and look
forward for that email man
who would be here for sure i i genuinely
have
that i was like i really should just
like uh
be be thanking uh my lucky stars
for whatever i put in that email because
like who knew
that's your angel got in your hand man
anyway guys
thank you for tuning into our mailbag
we'll try and do a little more often if
we can the schedules are good thank you
thank you thank you
for uh being here for me and zach and
the podcast and supporting us it means
the world to both of us
uh i'm so thrilled that we got to this
hundredth episode celebration
uh here's to 100 more than 100 more
after that
because this this podcast is really
special to me and important to me like
it's something that
i value um but you know
just because it's like uh like it
enables me to
um think and process and interact and
socialize sometimes in like a particular
way like i
i'm i'm so grateful and we couldn't do
this without everyone listening to this
right now so i just want to say thank
you from the bottom of my heart
you